very good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News a
triple whammy of strike crisis taking
place today talks that is we'll speak to
a real boss plus the new boss of the TUC
Kloss the latest from our Westminster
accounts Revelations we'll get reaction
from the smps Ian Blackfoot and the
shadow attorney general Emily Thornbury
and with claim and counterclaim from
Ukraine will speak to the Ukraine
Ambassador at half past nine it's
Thursday the 12th of January
bid to break the deadlock the transport
secretary says A Renewed offer will be
pushed on the table at crunch talks to
avoid more rail strikes as to other
unions meet with ministers today
Russia replaces its War Commander as
Ukraine's president disputes the capture
of the mining town of solidar
root and Branch reform the S P's call
for a rule change around MP's earnings
from second jobs revealed in a Sky News
investigation
a call to stop the forced installation
of prepayment meters after it's revealed
more than 3 million people were left in
the cold after running out of credit
Australia cancels its one day cricket
series against Afghanistan in response
to the Taliban announcing more
restrictions on women
flood warning parts of Tewkesbury in
gloucestershire are almost completely
cut off by flood waters with more bad
weather expected in Southwest England
and Wales
going ape will speak to a
conservationist at Chester Zoo revealing
the birth of the world's rarest
chimpanzee
[Music]
the transport secretary Mark Harper says
A Renewed offer will be on the table at
talks aimed at averting more rail
strikes officials from the rail delivery
group The RDG which represents trained
companies will meet with the rmt and the
tssa a lot of acronyms later on today in
another effort to break the deadlock
unions representing civil servants who
are planning to strike next month as
well as Junior doctors will also hold
talks with the government a lot of
chatting is it going to be hot air or
will we get somewhere let's find out I
should standing by for us in Whitehall
good morning Aisha
morning Kay well as you say there's a
lot going on today various disputes
across Industries lots of talks taking
place today and if we start by talking
about the railways well the rmt union
and the tssa will be meeting with the
rail delivery group today there's going
to be a renewed offer put on the table
according to the transport secretary and
there's speculation that may well
include a nine percent payoff although
that purely is speculation at the moment
what we do know is that on Friday a
backdated payoff of four percent was
rejected but a big thing in all of this
for the railway unions will be the
Clause that is specific to the driver
only operation that's something that
they say that they won't budge on so
even if there is a pay offer on the
cards here an increased one it will
depend on that as well so far unions
when it comes to the railways of blame
the government though the transport
secretary has said that he's helped
facilitate this new deal and that it is
more more than reasonable and then when
we move on to the civil servants well
the public and Commercial Services Union
PCS has a hundred thousand of its
members taking 24-hour walkout strike
action on the 1st of February and that's
going to be spread across
124 government departments and bodies
from the dvla to border Force including
the DWP as well so really affecting
anything from driving examiners down to
airport staff as well and then on top of
that the BMA will be meeting with the
health secretary to hold talks there as
well okay lovely thanks for now thanks
very much Aisha we'll keep an eye on of
course throughout the day here on Sky
News exactly what is happening with
those talks and also we've got union
leaders throughout the day on both on
this program and later on on Sky News
where else would you go to find out
exactly what's going on meantime the
foreign office says it's supporting the
families of two British Men missing in
the conflict zone of eastern Ukraine
after unconfirmed reports about whether
a body has been found
Andrew Bagshaw and Christopher Parry
have been missing since Friday the
foreign office has said this we are
supporting the families of two British
men who have gone missing in Ukraine we
are aware of recent reports and are in
touch with the Ukrainian authorities
the men were last seen heading towards
solidar in eastern Ukraine president
zielinski has denied Russia's claim that
it's taken the town Moscow claimed it
had killed hundreds of Ukrainian troops
while taking the salt mining town near
the city of bakmut but Ukraine's
President says fighting is ongoing
it comes as Russia's defense minister
appointed General garasimov as the new
commander of Russia's military campaign
in Ukraine the previous Commander
General surovitkin nicknamed General
Armageddon Who was appointed last
October will remain as a deputy
and later this hour joined by the former
Chief of the general staff that's Lord
Janet and also joining us after nine is
Ukraine's ambassador to the UK Vadim
pristaiko also making news for you today
new research from citizens advice found
that more than 3 million people run out
of credit on their prepayment meter last
year because they couldn't afford to top
it up the consumer Watchdog also found
more than 2 million people are being
disconnected at least once a month
so we're seeing unprecedented numbers of
people uh coming to us because they
can't afford to top up their prepayment
meter that literally means that they
won't be able to turn the lights on they
won't be able to heat their home over
the past year we've seen more people
with that problem than we'd seen in the
previous 10 years combined so it's a
real real issue
third largest party the SNP has demanded
route and Branch reform to the rules
governing MPS outside earnings and
donations the party's Westminster leader
Stephen Flynn has written to the Prime
Minister calling the current system
broken and corrupt it follows the
Westminster accounts project from Sky
News and tortoise media which revealed
that politicians have earned more than
17 million pounds in outside income in
just three years and that 38 of them
have taken on second jobs even though
the identity of their ultimate paymaster
is unclear Mr Flynn raised the matter
during pmqs yesterday let's take a look
let's reflect upon numbers and in
particular those numbers that were shown
away on by Sam Coates of sky does a
prime minister not find it utterly
perverse that senior members of the
conservative party are Feathering their
nest in this way
former leader of the SMP at Westminster
Ian Blackford is with us now it's always
great to see you thanks for joining us
on the pleasure to be with you um do we
need a complete overhaul of the system
yes we do because there has to be
transparency and there has to be trust
you know that clip that you just showed
there let me thank Skye and tortoise for
the work that you've both done but when
you've got MPS that are not been open
about where the learnings are coming
from and and of course being a member of
parliament is an important role you've
been put there by the electorate and
they need to know that you're doing your
job so there has to be transparency and
I think it is right that we see
legislation that cleans us up not that
long ago we had the expensive scandal at
Westminster it's important that MPS are
above reproach we've had the situation
of course by Ron Patterson was forced
out of parliament you've got the
situation where you have had MPS where
you've had paid advocacy these things
can't happen and we need to make it very
clear that politicians need to make sure
that they've got the trust from the
public for the job that they're doing do
you have a time frame
I think we did do this as quickly as
possible I think what does that mean
well I think that the prime minister's
got to look to bring forward legislation
within this session of parliament it's
an important issue you know we've come
through a situation where obviously
we've had the situation with Boris
Johnson everything that went on with
party Gates the standing of politicians
has suffered over the course of the last
few years so we have to take our own
responsibilities to make sure that we
have our house in order that we have to
be above suspicion that means that we
have to make sure that the rules are
tightened up nobody's saying that that
the things that MPS can't do but it has
to be fair and it has to be
proportionate and the primary
responsibility of any Member of
Parliament is to represent the
constituents I mean you've had a second
job in the past as we know is it
possible for MPS to have second jobs as
well as be an MP I think what we need to
do is actually have rules that the
public can have trust in when I came
into Parliament I had a couple of
non-executive directorships and I gave a
commitment to the 2019 election that
would bring them to close but of course
these were things it didn't have any
interference at all in the job that I
did I was a full-time member to
Parliament but I've chosen that I would
not do that but we need to make sure
that the public can have confidence in
the way that MPS are going around the
business and the primary responsibility
is to represent their concessions and
there are no conflicts of interest
because that's important
why is it the SMP you think that is
taking the lead on this overhaul and not
say labor well I think this has to be an
across party issue because all of us
have a responsibility and I would appeal
to parliamentarians Across the house
let's make sure that we take appropriate
action we need to be sure that we can be
judged by the things that we do in my
plea to colleagues like make sure that
we clean up politics you know we've got
the situation you're talking about
second jobs but there's all sorts of
issues around all party parliamentary
groups that's been raised as well the
fact that there's dark money involved in
many cases too we can't have this so we
need to make sure that we look at all
the mechanisms look at the way the
parliament operates let's make sure that
Parliament is above suspicion and that
we can all take pride and how we go
about the jobs I mean it's just that
we've brought all of this with tortoise
media together in one place with an easy
to use tool and why has something not
been done before now well I think people
have actually raised this I mean you've
had situations over many years I mean
you've had a number of prime ministers
that have gone in the very recent past
all of a sudden are generating really
quite substantial amounts of money Boris
Johnson has raised a million pounds from
speaking engagement
exactly so I think we need to look at
someone that's been a politician all of
a sudden are using the fact that they've
been in high office basically as a
calling card to get paid and so we need
to make sure this is police properly and
we need to make sure that people can
have trust and have faith in the job
that politicians are asked to do so this
whole thing needs looked at the whole
thing needs to look needs to be reviewed
we need legislation to do that and it
should be done on a no party basis and
I'm pleased that the SNP is the party
that's that's brought this forward
everybody else needs to step up okay
what do you say to those that suggest
that Stephen Flynn new job just
showboating no because I think at the
end of the day it's about that
responsibility that we have to the
public skein used tortoise has shown a
light on this politicians have got a
responsibility to act to make sure that
we make sure that we've actually got the
Best in Class politicians people that we
can have faith in nobody's saying that
there aren't circumstances where MPS
have come in and they've had other
interests you know you've got people
that have operated in public services
those that have acted as doctors for
example to give one uh to one case where
they can carry on in doing that they
need to make sure that they keep their
their skills up but we need to make sure
that the the jobs that the politicians
are doing is primarily about that
responsibility to have to the
concessions and they're not Feathering
their own nest that's what this is all
about Stephen Flynn was sat there on
Monday exactly where you are now he's
he's the new leader here at Westminster
I asked him about suggestions that it
had been a coup to unseat you how do you
feel about it okay I'm actually really
looking forward to the job that I've got
now I spent five and a half years as the
SNP Westminster leader I think I had
four Prime Ministers over that period
I've accepted and Euro was the first
Minister's business Ambassador and I'm
getting on with that job I'm also
commissioning a report in a green
industrial future for Scotland which I'm
going to take six months to do so I'm
really looking forward to the rules that
I'm going to be fulfilling and of course
continuing to work as a as a
constituency MP so it's a a new
departure for me using my previous
skills working in business working in
the city to make sure I can Shine the
Light on the future for Scott was it a
coup though look at the end of the day I
took I took the decision to to stand
down we have an annual election for the
the SNP leader I'd been Consulting with
the first Minister about the ways I can
strengthen the argument for Scottish
independence I'm really pleased about
the job that I'm going to be doing I'm
getting on with that making sure I'm
serving my constituents but I want to
make sure that I'm delivering the the
message is how we can Revitalize the
Scottish economy how we can deliver
sustainable economic growth in fact I've
now got the freedom to do that and I
look forward to having those discussions
with you and others over the course of
the coming months well your ultimate
leader is meeting our prime minister
later on today he's heading up to
Scotland does that show that he's
serious about the Union
you know I think there are differences
that of course that we have with with
Rishi sunak but there are times that we
have to work together there are
important things that the first Minister
and the Prime Minister have to discuss
but my message to Rishi is he has to
respect democracy it has to respect that
there is a mandate for an independence
referendum that the Scottish government
has but where that's appropriate let's
make sure that the two governments are
working together will she uh bring it up
with him today I think the first
Minister will use opportunities as the
time arises to make the case that there
is an independence majority in the
Scottish Parliament our government was
elected with the Mandate in delivering a
referendum Richie soon I should respect
that oh well should should your party
respect what the Supreme Court decided
because at the end of the day what we
want to make sure is that we have a
constitutional way of moving this
forward with respect the right of the
Supreme Court to make that judgment but
this is a political issue how often are
UK governments going to stand in the
face of the votes of the people of
Scotland let's remember the Tories have
lost every election in Scotland since
1955. this is about the will of the
people it's about the right of the
parliament nobody was saying that the
prime minister in in the UK before
brexit didn't have the right to have the
brexit referendum I mean the European
union accepted through the article 50
process the right of the UK to leave
what is the mechanism for Scotland to
leave the United Kingdom if it chooses
to do so prime minister has to respect
democracy at Before I Let You Go there's
a story in a lot of the papers this
morning about Boris Johnson's team
shredding documents ahead of this
investigation into what happened with
partygate thoughts on that I think it's
all behavior when he was in office he
didn't mean the office that he had and
of course we've got the investigations
that are still taking place at
Parliament and it should face the
justice of that committee but at the end
of the day I think this is a man that
breached the trust that was put in by
the electorate of the United Kingdom it
was a shameful period for our democracy
it's always great to see you thanks very
much indeed for joining us Mr Blackford
thank you thank you
and QR code we've been showing it to you
haven't we all week it's on screen now
use our Search tool and discover how
much money your MP receives it's all in
the Westminster account from Sky News
and tortoise media
you're thinking what's what's going on
about these front pages I'll tell you
the Metro suggesting that rail strikes
could continue for an extended period
with rmt leader Mick Lynch refusing to
entertain the idea of driver only trains
Same Old Johnson that's the story for
you that's the mirror front page which
carries claims that Downing Street staff
destroyed evidence ahead of a Commons
investigation into partygate
the times has news of a government plan
to let people keep their benefits and go
back to work to try to boost the economy
but for some it may be too late the
telegraph reports that up to three
quarters of a million borrowers may be
on the verge of defaulting on their
mortgages especially the Young
and finally the male leads with a new
report which says that pregnant women
and new moms are being abandoned by the
NHS as Services decline compared with
five years ago
now the Australian cricket team have
pulled out of a one-day Series against
Afghanistan in the United Arab Emirates
due to take place in March because of
Taliban moves to further restrict
women's rights let's find out more
should we stand by for us is Nicole she
is in Sydney for us today hi Nicole tell
us more about this story good morning
good afternoon Where You Are
well it's a significant step by Cricket
Australia and as you said the reason
that they've done this is because of the
ongoing and ever strengthening
restrictions placed upon women and girls
under the Taliban in Afghanistan now
what we've seen happen over the last few
months is a ban on women attending
University in Afghanistan they're also
restricted in terms of employment
especially those women who worked for
non-government organizations ngos girls
have been banned from high school and
increasing restrictions they're not
really allowed into parks and gyms so
Cricket Australia has decided to make a
stand it was due to play three separate
one-day Internationals against
Afghanistan in the UAE we've had this
statement from the organization I'll
just read it out for you Cricket
Australia is committed to supporting
growing the game for women and men
around the world including Afghanistan
and will continue to engage with the
Afghanistan Cricket Board in
anticipation of improved conditions for
women and girls in the country
Cricket Australia has also said that
they made this decision in conjunction
with the Australian government so they
haven't gone it alone here and it's
worth pointing out that while Australia
hasn't seen the same sort of numbers and
scale of Afghan refugees that you've had
in the UK there has been about 23 000
Afghan refugees arrive here in Australia
another 16 000 are due to come over the
next four years so that's a significant
number for a country like Australia and
in terms of sport interesting to note
that Australia actually brought in the
entire women's football team from
Afghanistan during that sort of
traumatic period of the Taliban takeover
okay Nicole for no thanks so much indeed
thank you
also making news for you this morning
Islamic state has claimed responsibility
for a suicide attack outside of the
Afghan foreign Ministry in Kabul which
police say killed at least five people a
nearby hospital has said more than 40
others were wounded in the bask
protests against Peruvian president Dino
burati's government have continued to
spread through the south of the country
reaching the tourist city of Cusco
Health officials say 16 civilians and
six police officers were injured after
protesters tried to take over the city's
airport where many tourists arrived to
visit Machu Picchu
Royal Mail says it's experiencing severe
disruption to its International export
service following what the company
described as a cyber incident customers
have been asked to stop submitting
export items while the issue is resolved
Lord of the Dance Creator Michael
Flatley has been diagnosed with what he
says is an aggressive form of cancer and
has to undergo surgery the 64 year old
dancer and choreographer is best known
in the Irish dancing production River
Dance which was first performed as a
seven minute interval break in the
Eurovision Song Contest in 1994.
still to come on the program before you
joined by Mick Whelan he's the leader of
the train drivers Union asleff who
believes there's zero chance of a
resolution to end the ongoing pay
dispute
joined by the former Chief of the
general staff Lord Richard dannett who
wants Britain to send more tanks to
Ukraine
they were searching for additional
classified material in various locations
after a batch was reportedly found in an
office used by the president from 2017
to 2090 when he was VP after the Obama
Administration our U.S correspondent
Mark Stone has the latest
well I think difficult questions
increasingly difficult questions for
President Biden as he tries to explain
these classified documents and why they
were where they were the first batch was
found um in November before the midterm
elections their Discovery only came to
light publicly earlier this week 12 or
so documents classified founded an
office that he once used here in
Washington DC from his time just after
being vice president under Obama
um we don't know the details of what was
in those documents President Biden has
not given any details about why they
were there yet but his team found them
they handed them over to the National
Archives at the time in November that
prompted them to have a look to see
whether any other documents had been put
in the wrong place and lo and behold
they discovered yes a second batch had
been now we don't know how many we don't
know how classified there were we don't
know where they were found but it raises
at the very least questions about the
carelessness with which classified
documents were handled by President
Biden now politically people are trying
to draw an equivalence between this
incident or the two incidents of his
missing documents and uh Donald Trump's
predicament with documents that he took
from the White House Down to Mar-A-Lago
his resource in Florida I think it's
hard to draw a neat equivalent for a
number of reasons quantity in the case
of Biden very few 12 or so Trump several
hundred intent Biden's team found the
documents handed them over immediately
and the suggestion is they were put
there accidentally with Mr Trump they
were taken intentionally from the White
House Down to Mar-A-Lago indeed that is
the subject now of an FBI criminal
investigation so there's an attempt to
draw an equivalence
um there are on Capitol Hill politicians
calling for an investigation I think
that will happen but a neat equivalence
well there isn't one questions though
for Mr Biden absolutely
well rail union leaders have warned MPS
there's still a lot left to talk about
if further strike action is to be
avoided mcwheeler knows all about it
he's the General Secretary of the aslef
Union hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us I was listening to you with
interest yesterday when he was speaking
to a committee of MPS and you told them
we're further away than we started from
a deal how can that be
well we negotiate in good faith you
might not like our responses and none of
us want to be the position that we're in
but I found myself last week where
um a deal was announced in the Press on
a Friday afternoon late on a Friday
afternoon that can take many things that
we were around Red Lines we'd already
said no to many things we hadn't
discussed and basically were destroyed
our ability to actually eradicate every
agreement we've made in the last 140
years locally and nationally with no
rights renegotiate no trade Union is
going to give up the ability to speak my
office members
other plans for new talks what's going
to happen next is and the industry know
this they've been dealing with this in
the prime side sector for two two and a
half decades that any deal has to go to
my board my exactly committee
um I naturally won't be recommending
they will make the decision
um and depending on what they decide
we'll dictate whether we go back into
that format of talks again or what we do
in future
train drivers earn a lot of money 60
Grand the offer we're told from the Rel
delivery group describe it as a landmark
outline proposal it would give you eight
percent over two years which would mean
that pay would go up to about 65 000
pounds is that not enough it's not quite
true a trouble is it's average salaries
for train drivers more than that some in
the city company some earn more and in
many years they earn significantly less
about the reality of the deal was that
it was 14 RPI last year we're currently
running something similar this year we
haven't had a pay rise for four years in
effect it was a 20 pay cut for giving up
every term and condition we've got which
has been incredibly unfair and the value
of the deal would have been hundreds and
hundreds of millions of uh pounds in
productivity that you know the deal
itself doesn't make any economic sense
in English I perform but you must
appreciate that when we're seeing that
three million people have run out on the
prepay meters and I don't have any heat
and then we're looking at train drivers
who earn some of them over 65 000 pounds
that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money and neither you're right because
I've watched quite often do the politics
of envy you know we've what we've got
we've paid for in flexibility and
productivity down years
um people doing the 11 hour terms would
be a 20 minute breaks five and a half
hours six hours from the seat uh many
people still driving traction that is 29
40 years old with no toilet facilities
the modern Railway isn't quite as people
imagine it we see a nice shiny Intercity
train government to be how much
involvement do you think the government
has in the negotiations behind the
scenes well that's part of the problem
um we don't actually work for the
government we're done with the DFT or
the treasury I've got 15 strikes on and
15 talks so we're probably employee
battery from mobilio to first group to
trentalia to Advantage to whoever else
um but the people that we work for have
done a contractual deal with the
government limiting their ability to
give us a pay rise now we have free
collective bargaining now the value of
whatever you want to sell or buy is
precluded by what you're allowed to talk
about so part of this dispute arose from
the fact that when we went to talk to
our employers they said we can't talk to
you then we went to the government they
said no you've got to talk to your
employers so we months have been messed
around pushed on pillars to post before
we valid for strike action do you find
that this transport secretary is um more
willing to discuss with you I've met
with him once I found him incredibly
personable although apparently in the
Daily Mail they found me unpleasant
um
I hope not I don't find you unpleasant
um and you know I'm willing to talk to
anybody we don't want to be on strike we
don't want to be losing money we want a
resolution but let's be a fair
resolution so what is it that you want
what is what are the main sticking
points for you guys well having had no
pay offer for four years and all of a
sudden getting one that's so untenable
is frightening I want somebody to come
to the table and release the shackles
talk to us properly about the True Value
about what they want delivered how they
want delivered it and if everybody
thinks that we can just because of the
current crisis give up everything we've
ever had for nothing it doesn't work
that way how worried are you though that
your members train drivers will become
almost like dinosaurs it does look as
though trains are becoming more and more
into the future driverless trains
um well actually mostly Victorian
infrastructure can't
sustained driverless trains it's a
distraction
um before the pandemic we were actually
looking at
um who's looking for driverless
technology though isn't it sorry hs2
will be hs2 but it's purpose Bill most
trains run on Victorian infrastructure
with wonderful stations with Palisades
and nice pylons in the way and more
furniture that we can't see anything
also DOA wasn't designed for 13 car
trains with 1300 people one person on
there about our biggest problem is
society we've got train drivers and rail
staff afraid to go around part of our
Network at certain times day of night
prior to the pandemic sexual assaults
now Railways are going up 180 percent
with county lines with drugs people with
knives and acid the reality is the
society we live in when you talk to
passengers what they want they want a
cheaper safer but they want a visible
presence on Platforms in Booking offices
on trains and you can't have the
situation where the only person on the
railway is a train driver
are we looking at more strikes I believe
so when I don't know as I said we meet
next week to discuss the I'll call it a
non-offer
um and determine there's a lot of anger
out there I'm being inundated
um both on social media and in my inbox
by train drivers how dare you talk about
these things things that we have
rejected so I my board is eight train
drivers I imagine there'll be an equal
amount of passion next week
and so you will continue to strike um as
far unless you get the deal and it
doesn't look as though you're going to
get what you're looking for at this
stage the government though um is
bringing in legislation which means um
that will that you'll be breaking the
law if you strike
interesting
um what price democracy we might have
another debate another day between the
lobby and transparency Bill the protest
Bill uh the trade Union bill 2016 which
mechanic change in the courts and the
latest trade Union bill and this latest
legislation
um any form of indenture where people
can't withdraw their labor and can't
have a voice and actually we'll oppose I
imagine the whole trading movement will
do it
um we are moving in a direction of
society that does frighten me do you
think a way through this would be to how
because there's more and more unions
striking now members are striking
um a day of national strike a general
strike
um we have to be very very careful we're
allowed to do coordinated action and the
real problem is so many people have to
jump through so many different Hoops are
in such different places how you
coordinate the action when you have to
give different notice periods and what
you have to do to comply at the
legislation you could be very very
careful not to take secondary action
when you can be sued
um and also most trade unions are out
there looking to do the best for their
members the point of time I look at the
hail service and my wife works in the
health service for 48 years and nobody
wants to be out on strike and those
people deserve a massive penalize but
there is a day of action National Action
planned for the first of February by the
TUC do you think that that would be
viewed as a general strike I think it'd
be term as a general strike but from
what I know from the discussion that
took place
um an awful lot of trade unions are
still balloting won't be in a place to
give the appropriate notice they won't
be a general strike per se new all
members won't take part in that on the
first of all again I won't know until
Monday when I meet with my Baltimore
it's getting tight then is it two weeks
notice you have to give we'll get 14
days notes but we can do anything 14
days from Monday okay it's good to talk
to you thank you very much for joining I
don't find you unpleasant at all thank
you very much thanks a lot
now there are dozens of flood warnings
in place for England and Wales with
border counties and Southwest England
most affected downpours are expected to
continue with the Met Office yellow
weather warning for raining plays across
Wales and also South West England
as you can see Heavy Rain has already
left parts of a gloucestershire the town
of chicksbury is submerged as you can
see
our meteorologist John Robinson is with
us now hi Joanna it's good to see what's
going on in Tewkesbury it always seems
to get hit when there's a bit of rain
doesn't it
I know we've had significant rain
overnight over parts of Wales we've seen
50 to 70 millimeters of rain falling
over the brecon beacons overnight just
over a 12-hour period so significant
rain there over other parts of Wales and
into the southwest of England Heavy Rain
there too and all that rain's got to go
somewhere we've got this saturated
ground and that rain is just falling and
adding into the river systems and that's
why we're seeing flooding in certain
areas
already this morning I've seen the flood
warnings Rising it was 37 flood warnings
across parts of England when I first got
it this morning but it's already about
42 now so it's worth keeping an eye on
the flood warnings through the course of
the day as we will see further Heavy
Rain across Southern parts of England
and in fact through through this month
already we've already seen some areas of
whales and parts of Northwest England
have already nearly received nearly
their average January rainfall already
and we're not even halfway through the
month and we've seen these spells of
rain moving in because we've had this
sonal position of the jet stream across
the UK and that's been feeding areas of
low pressure in with spells of wind and
rain that will continue over the next
few days but there is a change over the
weekend we will see
um slight change to colder conditions so
the risks will change to more wintry
hazards as we go into early next week so
there is a change on the way but for now
further spells of wind and rain and you
know Gales at times too
okay for now thanks very much thank you
very quick look at the weather what's it
doing where you are this morning
unsettled for the next week at least
with strong winds and showers or more
prolonged rain and it's going to be
colder if you're in the South you're
going to need your big coat if you're in
the north long sleeves
weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at the impacts of climate change on
the planet we've got our dashboard for
you the right half of the screen shows
how the UK's power is currently being
produced no coal at all 50 Renewables
almost that's very good isn't it on the
top left you can see how much warmer the
Earth is now than in 1880 that's when
modern record keeping began and finally
bottom left the total amount of CO2
emissions in millions of tons
foreign
wipes Remain the biggest culprit in
sewer blockages according to Yorkshire
water they have caused 46 percent of its
blockages last year which had to be
cleared the company warns that wet wipes
contain plastic and do not break down
causing a block to the flow of pipes as
you can see here so what they're saying
is please don't throw them down the loo
put them in the bin instead 50 of
blockages caused by wet pipes
uh let's move on to what's happening in
Ukraine should we Russia's defense
minister has appointed General garasimov
as the new commander of Russia's
military campaign in Ukraine removing
the previous commander who served just
three months in the job so what is going
on let's uh find out from the former
Chief of the general staff and that's
Lord hello my Lord thanks this evening
joining us it's always great to see what
on Earth is going on what's your
interpretation well it's a very
interesting move that Putin has put
garasimov in charge now grazimov is the
chief the general staff so he is the
number one soldier in Russia and I think
you can probably interpret this as being
something of a sign of desperation
um Sarah covin who was put in place in
October had a fearsome reputation as
being the person that reduced Aleppo in
Syria to nothing so it was really felt
that he was the really hard man that
could make a difference well he clearly
hasn't been able to make a difference
the other problem is you've got quite a
tension between mercenary groups and the
proper Russian armed forces the Wagner
group has been trying to take backward
for some time terribly Keen to achieve a
success and say to Putin or we can do it
even if your army can't do it but
actually they're struggling and they
haven't done it very well so this attack
on solidar which is a way of trying to
get to backward is another throw of the
dice but it's really interesting that
Putin knowing some desperation has put
gerasimov in overall charge what's
happening in solidar
well it would appear that some pretty
World War One tactics are being employed
um a large number of what do you mean by
that a large number of Russian soldiers
probably many of those recently
conscripted in the Army therefore pretty
poorly trained have been thrown forward
in sort of human wave type attacks and
satellite imagery shows a vast number of
dead bodies in the area where there's
fighting going on the Wagner group tried
to claim a couple of days ago that
they'd taken solidar both the Russian
and the Ukrainian Ministry of Defense
said well actually we're not quite so
sure about it so this actually
underlines the tensions between the
commanders of the Wagner group that
individual is trying very hard to get um
a high profile with Putin himself and
the tensions and the leadership of the
Russian army hence Putin has put
grazimov in overall charge it's a bit of
a last throw of the dice it's a little
bit like General Patrick Sanders our
chief the general staff suddenly being
sent from London to wherever we've got a
campaign going on because the
government's getting desperate so it's
it's very interesting to watch this
development what do we know about the
Wagner group
well we know it's a mercenary group
that's been in existence for quite a
number of years it's been a kind of
proxy for Russian foreign policy and
Russian military around the world
um pretty active in sub-Saharan Africa
for example
um it's a pretty nasty organization uh
it's it's led by someone with a very
very murky background who is I'm sure
you've shown the pictures in the past of
him going around prisons
um
promising
um Freedom if you come and fight to
convicts so it's populated with a lot of
pretty nasty people who've got not much
to lose in life I mean if you've been
sentenced for some foul crime and you're
in jail for probably the rest of the
rest of your life the opportunity to at
least try and save a bit of your life by
going to fight is quite a high
motivation so it's it's frankly it's a
sort of typically Russian move you'd
never see it happening in the west and
it's pretty disgraceful actually
suggestions that they may be responsible
for The Disappearance of um two men two
British men Christopher Parry 28 Andrew
Bagshaw who is 48 and suggestions that a
body has been found
well I I mean I can't comment on on that
detail I think
as far as those two are concerned one
has to say well top marks for them for
wanting to have the human motivation to
go and help but of course I think
anybody thinking of doing that must
realize that the risks are pretty high
so if you are motivated
um and I would advise people not to go
and become mercenaries but people want
to go out to that part of the world as
Aid workers to try and help well the
motivation is admirable but they've got
to make sure that their Jolly careful to
look after themselves and that they
don't put themselves in undue in undue
danger there's always some danger but
they should be really quite careful of
measuring the risks to their own
personal safety talk to me about
Challenger tanks we're suggesting that
uh 12 will go that's what Ben Wallace is
suggesting is that enough
well I don't think so
um I mean I I wrote a piece in one of
the newspapers yesterday saying that um
the principle of sending some is Right
12 sounds pretty tokenistic to me given
that we're only planning in this country
to upgrade to Challenger 3 status
136 of our tanks and we have many more
than that it would seem that 12 is too
tokenistic and I would suggest sitting
25 or 30 or even as many as 50. that
would make a real difference How would
how does it make a difference on the
battlefield
well where we are in the campaign is
we're probably going to see the Russians
Mount some other form of offensive
um late winter early spring
the ukrainians Now supported even
increasingly by the west and
particularly if we decide to give them
tanks and infantry fighting Vehicles
should then be strong enough to mount a
significant counter-offensive and if
they can do that well there is a chance
that they could
strike decisive blows on the Russians
perhaps even to break the morale of the
Russian soldiers
and of course what's so important about
that is that I can't see most people
can't see a negotiated settlement at
this war the opening positions are just
irreconcilable so if there's going to be
a conclusion to this war in 2023 it's
going to have to come on the battlefield
so the point really is that the West
America France Britain Germany really
needs to get stuck in and behind and
provide offensive capability to the
ukrainians so that they can mount an
effective counter-offensive break the
will of the Russian army and actually
win this war that's what it's about now
we don't want to be here in a year's
time okay talking about the same things
is it not though a serious upscale by
NATO countries or in the situation in
Ukraine where does that leave us
it's an upscale in terms of the
capability but it's not an upscale in
principle we have been providing all
kinds of military hardware to the
ukrainians really since the start of
this war and indeed before this is
different it's not it's not as if we're
saying there should be a no-fly zone and
NATO aircraft will be flying over over
Ukraine that would be
tantamount to the West actually
physically getting involved with our own
Manpower this is merely an upping of the
scale of equipment that we're giving
them and giving them an offensive
capability I don't see the issue of
principle there and as I've just been
saying I think it's the right thing to
do to give the ukrainians a chance to
win this war Because unless they win
this war this war is going to drag on
how finally how secure is Putin do you
think in his position
I think is increasingly insecure
um I think he's insecure from a variety
of threats one is the ultra nationalist
not Ultra hardliners in the Kremlin who
don't disagree with the war but disagree
with the way that he's been running it
um and then I think there are others who
actually are increasingly beginning to
realize that this whole special military
operation are worn out by Any Other Name
is doing no good for Russia's reputation
no good for Russia's economy and
therefore there are other groups that
could be putting pressure on him I've
I've said it before and I'll say it
again I think the group of Russian
leaders who are probably the most
disaffected at the present moment are
the Russian military leaders headed by
karasimov if he could find a plan on the
moral courage to see it through I could
see a palace coup a Kremlin coup being
led by grazimov because the Army is
absolutely fed up with the interference
that Putin had been exercising
personally they're desperately upset if
you like by the way that corruption in
their procurement system has produced
some weapons that are manifestly
inferior to Western weapons so I think
we need to watch karasimov quite quite
carefully he could be the one for the um
Julius Caesar moment to stick in the
knife and do you think that Putin is
very aware of that which is why we've
seen the latest development I'm quite
sure he's aware of it he's probably
trying to hold grazimov in quite close
but also putting the stakes on
jerusalemov that um if you fail well
then you're out
um so I think what's going on in the
Kremlin and of course we don't know in
detail we're only picking up scraps of
information and trying to analyze them
but I think it's a very interesting time
of what's going on in the Kremlin at the
present moment keep your friends close
and your enemies closer that's it okay
okay my Lord thank you very much and you
for joining us thank you
um I mean well actually just to let you
know that we will be speaking to the
Ukrainian ambassador to the UK in the
nine o'clock hour here on the breakfast
show this morning so do stay tuned for
more on that meantime new research
suggests people who are suffering with
long-term effects from coronavirus
should expect their symptoms to resolve
within a year a team of Israeli
researchers have found that mild disease
does not lead to serious or chronic
long-term morbidity
somebody who knows an awful lot about
that Dr David Lloyd London GP of course
hello to Dr Lloyd it's good to see you
this is good news right
I think it is yes it's great uh it's
come out of Israel which as you know is
a a really very important country that
got their cut their population
vaccinated very quickly uh and they're
really done very well out of covered uh
and this is this research seems to look
at the alpha and Delta variants of covid
and seems to say that if you've got
pronuncated with lots of symptoms and
breathing symptoms in particular yeah
you're going to get better within a year
whereas we were very worried that this
is going to linger on for a very long
time so yes very good news and the other
bit of good news in it is that you uh
there is yet more evidence that if
you've been vaccinated you're less
likely to get the the prolonged covered
as well
um do people have long covered and don't
even know they've got it
oh you ask all these very difficult
questions I I think so I think there are
a lot of people with an awful lot of
symptoms at the moment where we're
really struggling under the sort of
triple threat of all these viruses lots
of nasty flu around at the moment uh and
uh it's it's very difficult to
distinguish them because we don't do
routine testing anymore but I think
we're seeing an awful lot of people with
covid who might just have we're just
having minor illnesses at the moment so
yes no I think it's a a very good point
there are lots of different strains of
covid and as we know Omicron being one
of the really challenging ones Delta
there's a new one I think in the United
States at the moment does that impact on
on whether you get long covered or not
does it depend what strain you've had
well that's that seems to be the the
inference from this research this is
just looking at the alpha and Delta so
we've got to wait for more data on the
the Omicron wave to see whether that
makes a difference to this particularly
particular part of the covid problem
yeah
okay and as far as people who are still
getting covid is it still the threat
that it was
oh dear
um I don't think I think you and I and
people who are who are at low risk are
uh it's now part of a part of life that
you're you're going to get covered uh I
think that the people who are very
vulnerable still are still at risk uh
and hopefully they've all been
vaccinated so that the there is a risk
there is less chance of breakthrough
infections uh but it's still around uh I
admitted two patients with covert last
week as a GP so um we're all we're all
sitting there watching it and just
desperately hoping that it'll come under
control uh 873 people died from covid
last week so it's not going away that's
a little bit on the week before so we're
we're we're we're just learning to live
with it but living with a terrible toll
um let me ask you one final question if
I may about
um a survey done by McMillan cancer
support saying almost half of cancer
patients have had to fight for treatment
on the NHS cancer treatment is obviously
time sensitive why isn't it being
prioritized do you think
well it again I'm afraid it all comes
down to to finding it really difficult
to see your GP uh the really worrying
statistic is about one quarter of
cancers are now diagnosed in emergency
departments those departments that are
absolutely overflowing and they're
having to diagnose cancer because people
can't get to see their GP and
unfortunately when when someone comes
into the emergency department with
cancer it's usually at a at a late stage
so yes we've got a lot of work to do
with cancer and I could only say to
everybody please if you've got any of
what we call the red flag symptoms of
cancer and you can go to cancer UK the
website or or or or anywhere to look up
those symptoms please do contact your GP
because once we know about it that the
system the two-week weight system the
the the the the the NHS has in place is
still working and you all should get a
diagnosis uh within a month and
hopefully start treatment with a month
if you've got it as well so we the aim
with cancer as you all know is to is to
catch it in stages one and two where
where we can really go for cure
okay doctor it's always good to talk to
you thank you for taking the time thank
you thank you very much
now Prince Harry has criticized the way
the media has reported on his new book
saying he's been taken out of context
and claiming that a dangerous lie has
been spread that he boasted about
killing 25 Taliban while serving as a
soldier in Afghanistan joining us now
from Los Angeles is a royal reporter
Sean Mandel hi Sean good to see you
what's your big takeaway from this book
I think the big takeaway from the book
is the No Holds Barred attitude of it
and also these sort of dissonance
between what I think Prince Harry
believes he is doing with this book and
maybe what outside perceptions are of
that uh certainly he feels that this
book is actually going to increase his
chances of reconciliation with his
family and actually also you know Garner
more support to his side when I think
that both of those items are up for
debate
um he's doing late night talk shows he's
done all sorts of interviews how's he
being viewed in the US at the moment
you know Prince Harry's support is still
very strong in the United States as is
uh the support for his wife Megan Markle
The Duchess of Sussex he was on uh
Colbert Stephen Colbert show the other
night and got a standing ovation chance
of Harry Harry uh from the audience when
he uh did that and that by the way was
the first live uh TV audience that he
had been in front of for a late night
show he had previously been on James
corden's show but that was during a
pre-taped uh segment out and about
through uh the streets of Los Angeles
this was in studio with an audience
though taped ahead of uh Monday actually
but people here are definitely still
flocking to his side but there is a
little bit more uh there's a larger
faction of people who find the whole
Affair rather cringe-worthy to be honest
uh and that is seen not just on social
media to where there have always been
people who are detractors of the couple
in addition to those who are supporters
but also if you look in the mainstream
uh US news media which has typically and
traditionally up until this point up
until the documentary and this not and
this book that he wrote have all been
very supporting of the sussexes uh or at
the very least sort of neutral
throughout and now there is a little bit
more questioning whether or not uh
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle and The
Duchess of Sussex whether this sort of
tour of airing their grievances is some
view it to be has run out of steam and
maybe run its course
um our weary King is out and about today
with the public how is he viewed in the
U.S
I think more negatively uh certainly
than uh his son uh Prince Harry uh and
his wife I think that unfortunately or
fortunately depending on where you know
you fall along these lines uh King
Charles is always going to have a more
difficult relationship with uh American
uh with American subjects American
citizens because of the Specter of
Princess Diana that still hangs over how
many Americans uh feel about Charles
about the king and that only gets
churned up even more every time you know
there is a book for example like spare
every time there is a new season of the
crown and there are new people new
generations of people who are
discovering sort of the war of the Wales
is that dominated the 90s uh prior to
Diana's tragic passing in 1997. so I do
think that that unfortunately is
something that uh for the king anyway
that is something that was is always
going to impact his popularity here in
the United States and the final thought
before I let you go do you think the
hurricane that is Harry is now blowing
through or do you think we're going to
get more
well I'll just say that this is a book
that is part of a multi-book deal that
the sussexes have with a penguin random
house and you know this whole uh you
know Affair has been drawn out over uh
several years now so I don't think that
uh the hurricane has fully subsided uh
maybe a new one coming in uh shortly or
in the coming months we still have the
coronation ahead of us and we haven't
had a book from Megan yet so something
I'm looking forward to
[Laughter]
um it's good to talk to you thanks for
staying up late we really appreciate it
thank you
my pleasure
um so I finished the book
um if you've not read it yet have a look
see what you think apparently it was the
fastest selling non-fiction book in the
US the UK and Canada no there are a
cluster of stars 200 000 light years
away from Earth which could provide
insight into how the first stars were
formed more than 10 billion years ago
new images captured by the world's most
powerful telescope show gas and dust
developing into Stars near the Milky Way
no idea what I'm looking at astronomers
believe studying the region could help
them understand how the first stars were
formed two or three billion years after
the big bang so there you go it's very
pretty but I'm afraid I'm sure very many
people who are cleverer than I will be
able to tell me exactly what I'm looking
at you can tweet me directly if you
would like to at K Burley could it be
crunch time for the transport secretary
Mark Harper who said A Renewed offer
will be on the table for rail unions the
general secretary at the trade Union
Congress that's Paul Novak will be with
us in the next hour we've also heard
already from asleff the train drivers
Union they say that there will be more
strikes on the railways just what you
wanted to hear over your conflicts I'll
see at the top of the top of the hour do
you hope so
[Music]